ae a todo o pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dark sejam muito bem vindos a mais 1
bilhão
eu acho que é um dia muito especial
porque hoje nós vemos um skatepark eu
vou para uma criança encontrou moto e lá
nós vamos tentar fazer muitas acrobacias
e muitos saltos muito louca' e ser vai
ser muito divertido porque eu adoro
pintar no campinho méxico aconteceu um
problema alguns dias atrás eu tentei
pintar o carinho na sala e eu fui contra
um sofá e eu acabei por perder uma peça
uma das peças principais do carro vamos
mostrar o que é e como podem ver esta
peça aqui
esta proposta tem basicamente esta é seu
prendendo a roda é que a parte da frente
do carro está a partir aquino maior
nisso basicamente seu andar com o carro
assim vai ao ar todo torto então não vai
voltar eu descobri também que eu acabei
por partilhas de ferro tanto que eu já
tentei colocar aqui e ela está colado
mas como é passar pela loja ou mesmo
arranjar em que esta peça ou então colar
basicamente este problema como vocês
poderão ver o ferro que prende as rodas
suspensão está à partida então eu tenho
que passar pela loja e é isso que eu vou
fazer agora eu espero que o time consiga
arranjar isso porque senão não vou
conseguir ir para o skate park porque o
carro não vai poder andar é ouvir mas eu
acho que vai dar tudo certo e vocês são
nossos aqui no canal pessoal já se
inscreveram ou que deixem muito leve que
neste vídeo porque isso ajuda muito o
canal e os ensaio que vocês gostam de
ver o conteúdo eu já tenho umas ideias
muito louca pra fazer com o carrinho
caiu só esperando consertá lo eu vou
fazer muita coisa então deixe mesmo
muito laquê pessoal foi muito canal e
agora está na hora de montar a loja
online solo tão nervoso que eu espero
que eles não consigam arranjar um
parceiro que eu quero muito fazer isso
perigoso se tiverem já haver esta
partida porque quando fiquei por aí vai
mostrar um carro ai ai tornassem 50 eo
galo tem um nome
leiam o pessoal acaba de sair da loja e
dinheiro o que aconteceu eu conseguir
parar o carro conseguir arranjar as duas
peças que ainda bem que vinha se toca
que parar só lembro daquelas aqui branca
tenho umas peças que eu comprei novas e
o caso vai ficar muito diferente mas
isso é uma surpresa agora para um novo
videoclipe portanto fique atento é
provocar o quinto já agora como y é que
vocês acham que é assim que eu comprei
uma carapaça nova acham que eu comprei
umas rodas novas acham que eu comprei
com que
comentei mas desde já que é uma coisa
bem grande porque o saco tá cheio e
agora vamos pra casa porque tenho
trocado roupa tem que buscar as baterias
proteger e gastam cada 800 para que seja
o suficiente para andar com o carro hoje
à tarde inteira costumam durar 20
minutos então eu vou tentar aproveitar
uma sombra lápis o próximo destino skate
park para nós chegamos aqui no skate
park infelizmente que assim da casa do
carro méxico está a funcionar a lei
o papa muita potência só vejam só as
rampas nas parque
[Música]
para o psol a primeira coisa que eu vou
fazer vou fazer aqui um pouco do
freestyle só perceber como é que
funciona o terreno e já vamos ao parque
nos campos por lá mas não carregar muito
achei um clube mesmo só voltou a quebrar
ou aí eu penso saiu se está a propor
outra vez no clipe
puro marketing está também no canindé
calma pessoal funcionou fazendo aí
[Aplausos]
amadora
para laptops vamos tentar andar aqui no
habitáculo e eu peço desculpa pelo vento
mas não consegue controlar muito vento
mesmo mês para lá
[Música]
agarram a qualquer coisa está sem força
nem tenha ido embora uma pessoa hoje é
um novo dia como vocês puderam perceber
o carro avaliou ontem portanto eu tive
que faltar a casa teve que voltar a
colar as peças e hoje também já tinha
cara passa do carro olha só
mas pelo menos já a funcionar então
vamos continuar o vídeo para la paz
como o meu andar muito rápido
o acidente evento elas o primeiro que
nós vamos fazer vai ser nesta campanha
não sabe se o carro conceito 321 vagas
o papa deu muito certo aqui
[Música]
acidentes existem tudo agora a produção
pode escolher a campa a lei esta que já
meu deus vejam só inclinação olha esgoto
está muito inclinado que o caso vai só
para evitar esse mortal e vai querer
outra mesmo meu deus vamos estar para lá
[Música]
então funcionário resolveu então foi
muito alto para isso oferece proteção
para fazer até mesmo
[Música]
agora não corram vai a outro acidente eu
tenho que dar prefeito
[Música]
foi vice-prefeito para 321 bairro só
agora vamos tentar uma coisa muito
arriscadas não há vedação e enfrentar
rampa eu vou tentar saltar cook na rampa
de forma a colocar passa avançam e caiu
lá no outro lado vamos tentar isso pelas
minhas contas tem que ser uma rampa
destas inclinadas porque se for é
direito e não vai faltar então vamos
tentar saltar aqui nesta campanha que
está fazendo os cálculos já está pronto
meu deus está muito errado 32 com um
baixo só está funcionando em pacheco
terra contou e produção voltou precisa
pensar nele porque o ferro
meu deus calma o cientista também não
quero arranjar depois vai dar certo e na
hora certa
só preciso um pouco de força conta com
uma concentração e funcionou e não
acredito como é que o salto e votação a
lançar o desafio vou tentar saltar em
lei naquela rampa
agora eu não sei se vai saltar lá dentro
no fundo só que fazer já comentei em
baixo o que vai acontecer vamos lá
tentar
vamos usá lo agora foi mesmo escutei
frente ao computador pessoal vejam só
que aconteceu frei acabou de partir o
ferro e não foi o feto já estava perdida
o ferro no financiamento novo lei partiu
do princípio plásticas nem sequer dá pra
encaixar porque para casa outra vez
consertar o carro não está agora muito
alto mas vamos disse ainda que só vou
tentar andar com um mesmo assim por lá
vou riscar vou arriscar
como vocês podem ver que haja muitos
tentasse uma peça e continuando mas
mesmo assim vou tentar saltar aqui para
lá 321 bairro
luisão está fazendo um barulho muito
estranho copa da holanda que se passou
aqui a lei
eu acho que é perigoso mesmo pessoal eu
acho que foi nesta casa sabia disso já
não funciona o estaleiro o motor
funciona mas seu nome ainda deve ter
saltado de alguma roda ou qualquer coisa
assim não funciona eu sabia que não deve
ter saltado mais de manejo karpin
calcinha quando jamil como funciona nem
produções destino
eu também gravo o teu padrinho tavinho
santos publicamente como é que um carro
elétrico do fumo
a sua única solução e voltaram para casa
e perceberam que quando seu carro e que
já não conseguia andar mais porque é que
isto acontece e não só as chaves da casa
que vocês poderão ver voltámos a não ter
sorte com carinho acho que acabaram por
entregar três peças seus parentes que
então a roda ao carro e uma roda dentada
que está dentro do motor que também já
não roda então essa peça tem que ser
substituída mas eu acho também que os
grevistas muito boas porque eu acabei
por dar títulos quatro a cinco saltos
muito lucros mesmo vocês acabaram por
ver isso então só a única coisa que eu
queria fazer agora é consertar o carro
vou deixar o carro mais potente e talvez
eu coloque umas peças de ferro assim uma
parte tão facilmente escalar vou trocar
as rodas também trocar muita coisa aqui
porque também já comprei algumas peças
novas em que eu vou fazer todas as
mudanças e a partir do caso não vai
partir tão facilmente e deixei muito
lactose quiserem eu vou também o skate
park para fazer mais e curvas risco que
tenha muitas mais rampas que toma possa
fazer a mesma coisa mas acabei por não
fazer o quarto gol e estava muito vento
estava muita coisa contra o vídeo mas eu
vou votar só lhe vai dar tudo certo mas
é preciso saber se vocês gostam desse
conteúdo então não tive muito o leque
mesmo então esse pessoal espero que
vocês tenham gostado aqui deste vídeo
não for escrito aqui no canal inscrevam
se mexem muito mike e esse pessoal
fiquem bem até a próxima
[Música]